there's the keeping track of everything
and then there's a lot of people out
there who that is a huge problem for
them but the second problem then becomes
like okay what do I do right like I have
all this stuff and all these different
exchanges do I buy some do I sell some
do certain times of the year should I
sell right before the end of the year
you know how do I harvest lost like all
of these very complex things that in
traditional finance either there's
financial advisors that are helping
people do it or they're professional
traders right they they actually are
spending all day long thinking about
this in crypto that doesn't seem to be
the case in many cases how do you guys
you know won't think through that and to
try to help solve that problem yeah the
good news is you know we don't have to
reinvent the wheel there's lots of very
intelligent people who have been
thinking about this outside of crypto
excuse me for regular finances for a
long time and many of those things and
those strategies and tools can be built
for the crypto ecosystem and that's a
lot of what we're doing there are
certainly lots of new sort of nuances
and idiosyncrasies about crypto currency
specifically and that is what makes it
challenging to build the tool in the
space but also what makes it really
valuable so I'll give you some concrete
examples you mentioned like figuring out
what times of years you might want to
make transactions and using strategies
to basically optimize your portfolio so
one thing that coin tracker offers that
can help people save a lot of money I've
used this myself to help save tens of
thousands of dollars in capital losses
is basically using tax loss harvesting
and for listeners who might not be
familiar with that basically before I go
into this just take the bus's
informational only it's not meant as tax
advice but there's a basically a tax
rule that will allow you to sell a
cryptocurrency asset that you have at an
unrealized loss and then buy it back so
the effect of that is you maintain the
exact same cryptocurrency positions as
you have before but your tax bill is
lower because you've internalized and
realized a loss that happened so just to
make that even more concrete let's say
you bought Bitcoin at 10,000
the coin prices dropped to 7k you can
sell the Bitcoin for 7k realize a three
thousand dollar capital loss and buy
back the Bitcoin you have the same one
Bitcoin you have a three thousand dollar
loss and you can use that to offset
other capital gains or if you have net
losses even ordinary income and then
therefore pay less taxes at the end of
the year yeah and I guess as part of
this there's the tax harvesting and I
think it's important for a lot of people
to understand that this is actually
different than nutritional when I talk
to a lot of traditional investors they
basically say oh there's something
called wash Trading or kind of the the
loss at the end of the year you can't
have a loss on unrealized an Amazon
stock let's say for the year December
30th sell the stock and then just buy it
back January first or second right that
wouldn't count as sexual tax harvest of
the losses here in crypto that's
different maybe kind of explain like why
that is yes and this is the kicker this
is why it's super interesting in crypto
specifically so as you mentioned
normally there's wash sale rules that
make it so that basically the IRS says
your loss is disallowed if you buy back
the same asset 30 days before or after
the disposal so with let's say the
Amazon stock example if you were just
selling the Amazon stock at a loss and
then buying it back right away you
wouldn't be able to claim that loss and
the idea there is you know you don't
want people basically taking advantage
of this tax loophole what normal and
financial advisers would do in this
scenario to still allow you to do this
is either wait 30 days so you get beyond
that period or find another asset that
is sufficiently similar in terms of your
diversification of your portfolio to
replace that asset with so typically it
would be if you have one ETF on you know
let's say Vanguard that you're then
selling and then buying back a similar
ETF on Schwab instead so that your
overall risk allocation is the same but
you can still take advantage of not
having to get your wash sales disallowed
in crypto the reason why it's different
is because
the wash sale rule is specifically
written in the tax code for securities
and because Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies are classified by the
IRS as property they don't fall into the
wash sale rule now there are some
exceptions some people would argue that
certain cryptocurrencies are security
tokens or SEC might rule that certain
longtail coins are clearly securities
and so for those they may fall into the
watch though rule but for bitcoins clear
bitcoin is not a security this would not
apply to it ether is also likely not a
security is we're not applied to it
stuff like these head coins you can
basically take advantage of this
loophole that doesn't exist for let's
say stocks for example yeah and how
important is it let's say that I buy you
know five Bitcoin but I buy them all at
different price points over a period of
time and at the end of the year or when
I go to sell two of them currently at a
loss but three of them I am I have a
game do I need to make sure that I sell
the two bitcoins specifically that have
the loss or can I just sell any to
Bitcoin and then basically say oh no
those are the two where I'm gonna take a
loss and the other three are fine okay
like how important is it to get the
exact Bitcoin you're now getting into
advanced but really really useful topic
that people can use to save a lot of
money an account Vince dream basically
what you're touching on is different
kinds of cost basis accounting methods
and the IRS typically requires people to
use one of two different methods one is
first-in first-out
meaning the first coin you get is the
first coin you sell so if you bought
five Bitcoin Bitcoin number one that you
got is the Bitcoin number one that you
sell they also have more advanced method
called specific identification that is
also allowed and in that method it's
kind of like what you suggested you can
pick exactly which Bitcoin you're
disposing of as long as you meet a
certain criteria like keeping detailed
records of what date and time it
happened which coin it was which wallet
it was coming from and going to what the
timestamp what the basis was etcetera
and all these are things that quaint
record
help you optimize and create records for
and the difference between kind of using
FIFO versus doing some kind of
optimization here can be huge in terms
of cash flow and in terms of tax
optimizations because if you bought
again one Bitcoin at a really low price
and then got another one later at a very
high price
you definitely are gonna have a massive
tax difference in terms of which one you
dispose or which one you trade for out
coins